dans le coup - je n'ai pas voulu parler
d'un attentat politique en entrevue aux
coulisses du pouvoir l'ancienne première
ministre pauline marois avoue avoir
regretté ce choix elle ne voulait pas
exacerber la relation déjà tendue entre
le parti québécois et la communauté
anglo québécoise
pourtant le 4 septembre 2012 tous les
critères étaient rassemblés
ce soir là les péquistes acclament leur
chef devenue la première femme à diriger
la province
daul coup ses gardes du corps se
précipite sur elle elle est évacuée en
catastrophe ce que martin qui vous êtes
sur place n'est pas très bien se passer
au même moment un incendie éclate à
l'arrière du métropolis
lourdement armés est ensuite arrêté par
la police il aura tué un technicien en
scènes et blessé un deuxième mais ben
visait la nouvelle première ministre et
ses partisans
pauline marois a quant à elle est
retournée sur scène pour terminer son
discours de victoire
en cette seule journée du 4 septembre
2012 la sûreté du québec avait
enregistré 6 menace sérieuse à son
endroit dix ans plus tard pauline marois
se désole de la libération d'un discours
anti démocratique qu'elle attribue à
l'élection de donald trump ce niveau de
violences d'agressions verbales et de
risques à un moment une tension
exacerbée durant les campagnes
électorales remarque cet expert de la
radicalisation il va falloir
probablement s'habituer à voir plus de
sécurité autour autour des candidats
autour des élus
parce que le niveau de menace augmente
la sûreté du québec a mis en place une
ligne téléphonique uniquement pour les
candidats mais est-ce efficace la
personne qui on déménage chez elle
devant sa maison par d'autres personnes
ne font pas la ligne
comprend pas cette ligne directement le
9 1 1 oui cette ligne en est issu mais
le camp même si 10 nitoo si en attendant
la sécurité se resserre autour des chefs
de parti mais le débat devra dépasser
l'ajout de policiers estiment des
experts il en va de la défense de la
démocratie ici marie josée paquet comme
radio canada montréal